read the celebration that old people do
still kick ass read to pretty much the
same thing read to surrett two's the
sequel to read and in read to the
surviving cast members of red one
they're still old they're still spies
and now they're on a new mission that's
not actually officially a mission but
it's them still kicking ass and you save
in the country or a couple countries and
I enjoy these read movies because it's
cool to see people or not 25 kicking ass
I've always thought old people kicked
ass I knew that because you know old
guys have those old man rock hands with
really thick calloused fingers because
they build decks out of wood and
concrete and beer and they lift houses
over their head and they have old man's
strengths why I never mess with old
people this movie celebrates that with
guns and Helen Mirren who is the most
attractive senior citizen ever and it's
really what I can say about red - it
really is more of what you liked about
red wine but it's not much more than
that it may be a little less than red
one it was cool to see these retired
spies kicking ass you know that was
awesome in red - it's like old retired
spies still kicking ass but now they
have young people in the mix also which
they had a couple of young people in the
first one this one seems like it has
more young people and it takes away from
the magic of the whole situation the
first one was like hey yeah we're taking
the young ones to school in red - you
have the returning cast members john
malkovich still makes the movie john
malkovich is awesome it's just like he's
just so crazy you have to think yourself
is he just playing a great role that's
making the red movies or is he John
Malkovich not knowing he's being filmed
at all I don't have an answer but I
didn't know he's entertaining his [ __ ]
in these movies Bruce Willis is still
with the chick from weeds and ultimately
she's one of those elements in this
movie where I'm like do you make sense
she is that element works like she does
spice [ __ ] in this movie and it's
entertaining to see her do spy [ __ ]
because she's just she sucks at it most
of the time but she's so willing to do
it you're like it's almost inhuman
people would not be so willing to do spy
[ __ ] well I guess some attractive chicks
from the show Weeds would in which case
good job Bruce Willis you have landed
that Anthony Hopkins is in the movie do
you really think he's gonna suck he's
not gonna suck Anthony Hopkins is really
good in the movie he's Anthony Hopkins
he can take most people to acting
any day of the week Storm Shadow from
the GI Joe movies is in this movie I'm
not a big fan of the GI Joe movies but
Storm Shadow kicks complete ass although
you do feel like he was just thrown in
the mix because I like alright we need
more cool martial arts [ __ ] and in a
movie with Old Spice Storm Shadow now
that's their and after that you have
more cool Spice [ __ ] and that's always
entertaining it's like the read movies
are the born retirement that is what it
should be called I had a point in read
to you do feel like the movies a bit too
long you're like okay you're now a
little too convoluted if you had taken
out a couple of these little plot points
or plot twists the movie would be a
little more cohesive but I see this a
lot of times in sequels it's a sequel to
a spy movie especially so they want to
make more twists and turns and have more
of that stuff you liked about the first
one for just more of it which means they
run the risk of overdoing it which
happens a lot in the end red 2 is more
of what you liked about red 1 but not
done as smoothly as red 1 did it I still
found it entertaining if you're a fan of
red one you'll probably like red too I'm
a sucker for senior citizen spies I will
say red 2 is a good time no alcohol
required so the red movies I haven't
reviewed red so red and red 2 have you
seen them what did you think of them
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you
[Music]